the other story we're all talking about
Harry and Megan chased by the paparazzi
there's conflicting information but
here's what we know from all the sides
today a source tells us the couple was
quote shaken fearful but thankful
everyone is okay certainly the memories
and Echoes of what happened to Harry's
mother was front of mind their private
security has never seen anything like
this in their entire career there were
about a dozen Vehicles cars scooters and
bicycles the public were in Jeopardy at
several points it could have been fatal
other accounts from h m
guard who spoke to see in to radio host
Charlemagne the God provide proof of
Harry and Megan's claims of Highly
aggressive Paparazzi his Gary literally
told us yesterday Paparazzi kept going
around in circles just to get a picture
of her and it was hitting Park cars but
one Paparazzi agency bat grid refutes
that claiming to E.T quote there were no
near collisions or near crashes but they
are conducting a thorough investigation
after four freelance photographers
submitted photos and videos they allege
reckless driving on the part of one of
the four SUVs from Prince Harry's
security escort paparazzi's came and
started taking pictures and then there's
the taxi driver who was with the pair
for about 10 minutes yesterday on a
media blitz here's what the driver said
aggressive they were behind us they were
standing in front of the cab they
surrounded the car and just went crazy
with the camera they kept their distance
that must have happened earlier if they
were being chased before but they did
seem nervous they just seem nervous yeah
so what's the Royal Family's take we're
told as of this half afternoon Prince
Harry hadn't heard from his immediate
family but since he and Megan have
stepped back from Royal duties the
palace generally does not comment on
their activities today it was business
as usual in the UK Kate visited a
charity Queen Camilla a school and King
Charles
he just had a brush with Hollywood
Stanley Tucci musician Nile Rogers and
Jerry Hollowell met the Monarch during
the prince's trust Awards Ginger Spice
kinda recreated this cheeky moment
nearly 25 years later wanted to go with
ginger hat and
I think she has a little Pat at his
bottom and there was kisses planted on
his cheeks yes with lots of lipstick and
we completely broke her protocol you
know
[Music]
good
foreign
[Music]